as of april 30th donald trump no longer
owns the lease to the trump
international hotel in washington dc
opened in 2016 the hotel's lease
reportedly sold for 370 million dollars
trump and his family will make an
estimated 100 million dollars from the
deal
that's much higher than the 173 million
dollars forbes estimated the hotel to be
worth in october 2021.
we don't know the full picture of how
successful the hotel has been but
because trump was present there is some
public information on the hotel from
when he was in office
trump reported 137 million dollars in
revenue for the hotel during his
presidency during the first three years
the hotel made between 40.4 and 40.8
million dollars in revenue but after
that the business started declining even
before covet restrictions kneecapped
several of the hotel's revenue streams
by his fourth year in office revenue was
down to 15.1 million dollars
additionally a house oversight committee
analysis found that the hotel lost about
73 million dollars between 2016 and
2020.
despite these numbers the hotel was a
hot spot for representatives of foreign
governments trump cabinet officials and
u.s senators a house oversight committee
report estimates that the hotel made
3.75 million dollars in revenue from
foreign governments during the first
three years of trump's presidency the
trump organization for its part says it
only made 459
320 from foreign officials at all of its
hotels resorts and clubs during trump's
presidency that number has not been
independently audited
in all we were able to identify 33
representatives of foreign governments
including malaysia's former president
najib razak and romania's president
klaus johannes 35 of the 65 republicans
who served in the senate while donald
trump was president either visited the
hotel or had a campaign that spent money
there
only one democratic senator visited the
hotel during trump's presidency joe
manchin
and through the federal election
commission forbes found that 3.21
million dollars in campaign spending
took place at the hotel since trump took
office in 2016. this includes 845 000
from the republican national committee
and 566 thousand dollars from america
first action inc a pro-trump super pac
[Music]
you